sind hier bei einem kaugummi gegen
korona das haben wir ihnen ja berichtet
in dieser woche und einer hat's erfunden
ein solches kaugummi gegen korona
nämlich der mann der eigentlich
mannschaftsarzt bei eintracht frankfurt
ist dr florian farb er ist mit dem
kaugummi jetzt nämlich auf dem markt
gegangen dass eine schaffen soll die
menge der viren im mund zu reduzieren
und das sagt er selbst dazu
das konnte sich so in diesem kaugummis
sind hochprozentige ätherische öle mit
eingearbeitet substanz nicht hin singen
quercetin
weizen kam extrakt der spermien enthält
und diese hochprozentigen öle und auf
substanzen haben in experimentellen
studien sehr kräftige antiseptische sind
desinfizierende effekte gezeigt und in
diesen kaugummi sind quasi diese stoffe
substanzen mit eingearbeitet also
wichtig der kaugummi heiko witt nicht
ganz ganz wichtig keine missverstehen
ist sozusagen diese richtung ersetzt
keine impfung und ist nur als additive
zu den bisherigen gegenmaßnahmen gedacht
und da trägt er wahrscheinlich bis zu
einem gewissen gewissen risikoreduktion
war ja ein kaugummi also gegen korona
kann das wirklich funktionieren oder ist
das totaler quatsch hygiene professor
klaus-dieter zastrow er gibt uns jetzt
die antwort herr zastrow was halten sie
davon
sind sie überzeugt sie ist natürlich
runter sich die idee hervorragend
und sie passt auch ganz ausgezeichnet zu
meiner these ich zwei jahren versuche
ich der regierung beizubringen dass man
die mundhöhle und das macht der kaugummi
auch die modelle desinfizieren muss dass
man die anzahl der viren
es ist ja eine viruslast entscheidend
dass man diese anzahl der viren
reduzieren muss da gab es von der
regierung überhaupt keine reaktion
und jetzt meine wo sie sagen wir müssen
nach gestern abend in der talkshow wir
müssen nach jedem strohhalm greifen also
da sage ich mal greifen sie nach der
bund desinfektion und natürlich auch
nach diesen kaugummi auf der jetzt
funktioniert kann ich nicht sagen aber
der kollege sagte er hat es
experimentell gemacht also
wahrscheinlich im labor
es ist auch bekannt dass diese
ätherischen öle von denen er eben sprach
in bestimmten mundwasser auch eine
antiseptische wirkung haben also dass da
irgendwas rede dass die virus anzahl
reduziert wird das scheint sicher und
ich finde es eine super sache man kann
sich ja dreimal täglich oder häufiger
ein kaugummi im mund stecken und wenn es
dann funktioniert wäre ist super aber
nochmal das ist jetzt verdammt wichtig
dass auch die regierung nicht mehr blöde
vor sich hin immer dasselbe macht
sondern mal dieser die tatsächlich die
viren abtöten nämlich in der mundhöhle
und das erzählen mal den seit zwei
jahren auch mal aufgreift und und
empfiehlt ich habe der bundeskanzlerin
mehrere briefe geschrieben ein schreiben
briefe ich habe eine anzeige in der
zeitung auch gegeben wo ich das genau
als wert überhaupt keine reaktion
man hätte hunderttausende von
ansteckungen verhindern können wenn man
die reduzierung der der virus lasse in
der mundhöhle gesenkt hätte versuchen
sie es dann demnächst bei dem neuen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz noch mal die
adresse wird dieselbe bleiben herr
zastrow aber ich bin da eigentlich gar
nicht so skeptisch dass das
funktionieren kann denn die logik
dahinter die erschließt sich einem jahr
nur wenn man natürlich schon corona
krank ist dann hilft es nicht mehr und
was ist wenn sich das virus eben nicht
nur in der mundhöhle aufhält sondern
weiter hinten da kommt ja der kaugummi
nicht hin da kommt die mundspülung nicht
hin ja also das dann hat es einen riss
man muss das präventiv machen dass noch
eine präventionsmaßnahme
man muss diese augen ist sage ich mal
regelmäßig kauen und nutzen natürlich
vorzugsweise immer dann wenn man sagt
meyer ich hatte gerade den mundschutz
vergessen oder oder die anderen hatten
ihn nicht dabei jetzt weiß jeder mal in
der s bahn in richtung dicken gesänge
drin dann soll man sowas machen wenn der
wenn die viren erst einmal im körper
sind eindruck eintritt gefunden haben
dann nutzt es leider der kaugummi nix
mehr auch die desinfektion die ich ja
schon so lange propagiere on ebay es ist
eine präventionsmaßnahme die aber
äußerst wirkungsvolle sind werden wir
brauchen das haben uns ja
die berührung erzählt wir brauchen eine
bestimmte viruslast damit es überhaupt
zur krankheit kommen also von zwei viren
erkrankt keiner und deswegen ist diese
virus reduktion egal ob das jetzt mit
dem mittel oder mit dem ist die virus
reduktion in der mundhöhle die ist von
ganz entscheidender bedeutung also
munter machen werden dann hoffentlich
auch
für den inhalten des kaugummis erreicht
insofern als präventionsmaßnahme und was
ich besonders schön finde auch an dem
kaugummi wenn er einigermaßen schmeckt
kann man das ja gehen kann man ja
überall aus der tasche ziehen und
ansonsten hat die mundspülung jeden
zweiten tag zu hause
ist genau also diese wirkungsvolle
maßnahme ja dass die bisher nicht
aufgenommen worden ist ist eigentlich
ein riesenskandal museums gesagt dass
kaugummi ist sehr praktisch kann man
überall schnell aus der tasche ziehen
ist aber auch sehr kostspielig kostet
glaube ich zehn euro die packung schon
viel geld er gibt es noch günstige
alternativen die man mal eben schnell
aus der tasche ziehen kann so eine
mundspülung ist ja in der bahn eher
unpraktisch
also nein ich gehe ich kenne nichts
preiswerteres aber ehrlich gesagt zehn
euro kann man jetzt sehen wie mein bild
für manche leute ist es sicherlich viel
geld aber die alternative ankum ii zu
erkranken die wäre mehr alle male zehn
euro wert mit zehn euro dann das
vielleicht zu verhindern also sollte man
jetzt nicht knausern und dafür angst die
sind vielleicht brechende bewegen also
sie würden das ding kaufen
naja ich hab ja meine eigenen wunsch für
aber ich
sag mal so grundsätzlich sage ich allen
deutschen leute macht das das ist besser
als alles andere was bisher empfohlen
morgen ist und sowohl
desinfizierende muschel als auch
kaugummi leute macht dass die reduktion
der viren im nasen rachen raum spielt
eine große rolle ob man jetzt erkrankt
oder auch mal nur leicht erkrankt oder
ob man wenn man es gut gemacht hat oder
auch zum richtigen zeitpunkt gekommen
ist nur leichter kann also auf jeden
fall also ich sage es mal wenn es
funktioniert und der kollege hat geprüft
ist es die 10 euro wert